Welcome to the lecture on database implementation.
So in the last lecture, we have looked at the storage part until we came to this part here, slotted pages.
So basically the problem that we have to address is how do we map database data, in particular records, which means tuples basically, to fixed size data structures, fixed size pages.
So the most well known concept for this is a so-called slotted pages concept.
So we have this page of a certain size, in this case here we say page 1, 2, 3, and this
has a certain size, for example we could say 16 kilobytes or perhaps a lot more than this.
However, something like this, 32 kilobytes, so a certain size.
And then we put the records on there.
So this is a record, we just write all the data that we have here.
If you just A, B, C, 1, 2, 3, and so everything is written as a byte range on the page.
And now where does the name slotted page come from?
We have a slot that references this record.
So this, for example, this slot here could point to that record.
And then we would address this record by the combination of page number.
So in this case we could say page number 1, 2, 3, slot, sorry, it's supposed to be 3,
1, 2, 3, slot 0, and that's, this is then the record. Now strictly speaking this is not,
oops, I messed up the
the number. So this is in fact the record 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
Oh, did it start from 0? 0, 1, 2, 3, 4. So this is in fact was slot number 11.
11, so I miscounted.
So this here is a number.
And so this then allows you to reference a certain record.
Now what you see in this page here, you see some more entries here.
So this is the regular record, so we just store here.
Now here you see a special case, namely a record that was moved to another page.
So this can happen, for example, if you insert records and then your page is full at some point,
and then you want to update the record to make it larger.
So for example, you want to change the string
AB and we want to transform it into a new string XYZ.
And this of course makes the string larger.
Now it could be that there simply is not enough space for this record,
for this longer string, because my page is full.
So what I do then is I move the new record on a separate page.
So here we call this overflow record.
We move it to a separate page and on the original page,
we just remember that this record existed and now what is this new number?
So here we store that the record was number 1, 2, 3, 7,
is now stored as a position 5, 6, 7, 6.
So this is what we store here.
This is a forward.
And we reference the new position.
Now the good thing about this forward mechanism is that we can now keep the original ID.
So we moved it to a server page because we didn't have space, but nobody knows this.
Now so this ID here keeps stable, so this record always remains, keeps this number.
It doesn't matter if it was moved to a server page or not.
So we always keep this number.
And this is important because it could be that this number is stored somewhere, for
example in an index.
So we might have an index on this table and this index references this tuple.
Now if we move this tuple to another page, I don't want to go through all the indexes
and update them.
Instead, I keep the ID stable and insert a forward.
Now of course there is a certain cost involved, because if you do this, if you have to follow
here, then we jump from one page to another page. This gives me another page
for all this cost me performance, but I hope that this is the exception. So most
doubles will not be moved to another pages, and this is absolutely true.
First, because most doubles are never updated, so the majority of the data
items are inserted and then perhaps deleted at some point, but they're never
updated most of the time. So frequent updates are rare, and therefore we can
expect that most of the data I could just keep it as it is. And the second thing is,
this, I mean in the worst case, we have to touch two pages instead of one,
but we will do two things to mitigate this. First, this chain will never get longer than two.
And that's why perhaps it's not obvious why this is the case, because it could be, of course,
that this page here is full two. Now, if somebody wants to update this overflow record and make it
even larger so it doesn't fit here so we want to make this here increase this
there's no space but what we do not do I draw this here now this dotted pages so
what we do not do I mean you put it on another page of course as of the now we
have a really large record now what we do not do is it makes a chain longer
because this would give me a very bad performance of course what we do instead
So don't do this.
Instead we update the link.
So we let this here one point is new position
and then clear this.
Clear because the override doesn't exist.
And so we throw away this.
And so my chain at most contains one hop.
So I might have to access two pages,
but never more than two.
So this is one thing.
And the second trick that we will see in a moment
when we talk about the implementation of the storage layout,
this chain we only follow if we come from an index.
So if somebody says, give me a record 1237,
so this means we directly jump, we explicitly,
so we come from index,
index, then we jump to, it takes this idea,
then we jump to this page here,
we find this record, we see, oh, there's a forward,
then we go to another page.
So this, if you come from index, this can happen.
ahead, if we come from an index, we did random access anyway, because we moved through a B-tree.
Therefore, we only do this, we only do this rarely, because we use an index only if there are few
entries. And so in this case, you'd have another page. If we instead scan the page, so if we do a
table scan, then we do not follow this link. So the performance penalty is only for point access,
So jumping to a specific record, scanning the whole, every page does not cost me anything,
even if I moved a record.
And we will see in a moment how to implement this.
Okay.
So this is a pretty nice concept, very flexible and quite popular.
So many systems, I would perhaps even say most database systems implement some very of this,
at least historically they have done this.
So this is a very popular way to store data.
Now we here we look a bit more closely how we implement this.
So this is now a zoomed in version.
And so we, if you start a page, we will usually implement it like this.
So we, in the page, we have a fixed size header.
So there's a fixed size header in the front.
And then we will have slots and tuples.
And now you see on this page, this slide here, I said, we put the slots on the front.
here we said we put the slots at the end now what should we do should we put it at the front at the
end and this doesn't really matter now so um depends on the small implementation details
sometimes it's a bit easier to put the slots at the front at the end but in reality this this
doesn't really matter if you want to put it at the front or at the end both as that so both things
exist there are systems that put a slot in the front and put them at the end here i will now
assumes that I put the slots at the front. But as I said, the difference is a minor.
Now, what is more important is that the slots and the data items themselves
grow against each other. So this means if I insert a new tuple, I will create a new slot here
and I will put a new data item here. Then if a new tuple comes, I put a new slot here and I put
a new data item here.
So they grow against each other.
Data grows in this direction, tuples grows in the other direction.
And the page is full of course when both meet.
So when the slots and the data items hit each other, so then the page is full.
Now why do we do this?
So why do we have this complicated growing against each other instead of just statically
allocating n slots and that is?
The answer of course is that we don't know how large the data item is.
So here it looks like a nice fixed size box, but this is just a picture.
In reality, this data item can have variable size, therefore I don't know how many slots
there are.
So if my data items are very large, then I will have only few slots.
If I have very small data items, then I will have many slots.
I cannot know this before.
In particular, I mean, this is probably most clear if you think about this, this could
be a string.
Assume the data item is a single string, so we have a tuple that consists of a single
string column.
And therefore you can never know how large the thing will be.
Because if the user inserts a lot of short strings, then we can fit many tuples on the
page.
If the user inserts many long strings, then we can fit only a few tuples on the page.
And we cannot know this beforehand, and therefore we cannot know how many slots to allocate.
And therefore the number of slots and the number of data items is dynamic.
Okay.
Now we have, so this is as long as you only insert, everything is nice.
Yeah.
So of course, everything gets a bit more ugly is the moment you do update and delete.
So because I grow and then here's another data item, then I have another data item.
And now somebody wants to, I mean, easy case is somebody just wants to lead this.
Okay.
That's not too bad.
And we can, yeah, so we will see what we do in practice is we will do nothing.
We will just remember that it's deleted.
And because what we would have to do is, we would have to do basically garbage collection,
which means we move all data items of, we cannot, perhaps it also delete this, we delete
multiple items.
Now, what we would want to do at some point is, we want to move everything.
So we want to move, for example, this here, and then we would move that data item where
this one was before and so on.
So we compactify them, move them next to each other.
But of course this cost me something, therefore I only do this if I have to.
So the first instance, if I delete a data item, I do nothing.
Now if my page is full, so data items and slots cross, but I know that I would have
enough space, I just didn't reclaim the space, then I do compactification, which means I
just move everything compact again so that all the holes are gone and then I can reuse
the space.
So I delay the compactification until I have to amortize the cost.
Okay, so this is, this is for deletions, for updates of course it's the same.
So if I update and the size does not change or it shrinks or it's the same, then I can
just update in place, of course I can just do data prime and then have an update.
If the size does increase, then I treat this internally as a delete followed by an insert
on the same page.
So then I do an insert on the same.
Again we might have extra difficulties if it doesn't fit, because it's too large, then
we must insert a redirection, insert it on another page.
But if this is not the case, then we just put it somewhere else and treat this as a delete
to reclaim space.
So this is a basic strategy here.
Now if you zoom into the header of the slotted page, so this is basically the fields that
we will need.
And so first one here, log sequence number, we will talk about this later in the lecture
when we talk about recovery.
This basically means we remember the last change on every page and we do this to cope
with crashes.
So if we crash, we must know what, which operation were performed on the page.
change on each page.
This is just a number.
Now this is a number.
And then the next one here is we store how many slots we have.
And this number of course grows dynamically if somebody inserts.
Then we store what is the first three slot.
I will say more about this in a moment.
And then we store two pointers.
Basically one is data start.
So where's my data here?
So, data start points here, if this is a tuple, then data start points here.
And if I insert now, if I insert new items, then I update my pointer to always point to
the first tuple, the first block here.
So you always point to the beginning of the data.
So this grows basically in this direction.
And now the last one here, free space, this is the space that would be available after
compactification.
because this is just what I said.
If you delete something, then,
so for example, if I delete this here,
then I do decrease the free space.
So if I delete, then I do increase my free space,
but I do not update the data start.
Now, because there's a tuple in front,
I mean, if I delete the very first tuple,
I can update data start and move the data start back.
But if I delete something in the middle, I do nothing.
I just increase the free space.
I say there is enough free space.
Now we see that in principle, so we say we have two things, let's call this effective
... effective ... oh, that's a long word.
Let's write it differently.
We say effective free space, EFS, I just made up this acronym, effective free space.
is page size minus header size,
minus slot count,
slot count times slot size.
Okay, so this is the space of this page, except the header, this was 3D header size, except
the space for the slots and of course, except the space of the data.
Let's write the minus somewhere.
So minus, minus, and this is the size of the data, the size of the data is page size.
Okay, so this is the effective free space and we realize of course that effective free
space is less or equal to free space.
And the interesting case of course is if they are not equal, because if they are equal then
I have no wasted space.
If they are not equal, so if effective free space is less than free space, then I can
regain space by running competitification.
So if it's less, if EFS is less than free space, then we can do competitification.
But we only do this if you have to, because competitification costs us something.
we can have many items in there.
So we don't want to do this every time we do an update,
but only if the other would otherwise be full.
And here you see a note on the slide.
A slide page can contain hundreds of entries.
This is something you should absolutely keep in mind.
I mean, if you have, for example,
to make an extreme case,
you have a 16 kilobytes page
and we have my tuple perhaps has only,
let's say eight byte tuples.
So then just say 8 bytes tuple and 8 byte header, 8 byte slot.
Could be that I have such a case and then I can of course fit 1024 entries and a bit
less because it's better for the header.
But let's say roughly 1000 entries on a page.
And, okay, so this is a clearly non-zero number and this means we must be a bit careful.
For example, if you want to insert something, what you should not do is check for what is
the first free slot.
Because if you do this for a thousand entries, remember if you do this n, if you do n insert,
so this is O of n square.
And because first entry of course only has to check one, second entry has to check two,
third entry has to check three and so on.
So after the nth entry we have to check n entries, other entries, n minus one, other
entries.
Therefore we have the order of n square runtime.
This is problematic.
So we do not want to do this.
So n square is bad.
So you should not scan your slots to find a file out was this free.
It's too expensive.
Therefore we use this hint here.
Now we remember what is the first free slot.
And therefore if you insert something and you want to check is there a free slot, you
look at this entry.
If there is no free slot, we stop immediately.
Otherwise we take the free slot and then continue scanning to the next free slot.
This usually means only a large linear scan over the data.
So this is basically a cache for our free slot.
Okay, and this number of course is only updated if you do deletes.
and we usually have far more inserts and deletes,
and therefore we don't have a lot of these.
So performance is pretty critical for the slotted pages.
I mean, you could say, hey, these are only 16 kilobytes or 32 kilobytes,
it's not that bad, but it's not true.
Whereas in reality, performance is quite crucial.
If you do a naive implementation, your slotted page will be slow.
Okay, now next question is, what is in the slot?
And so I just said we need 8 bytes for the slot, for example, but what do you really
store there?
And so basically we need two kinds of information.
First we need the offset of the tuple within the page.
We must know where it is.
So if, for example, if this is my page here, so on this here is now byte position 0, this
is byte position here, 2 to the power of 16 minus 1.
And so this is the last, or if I accept them, this of course without minus 1.
beginning at the end of the page. Now if my tuple is for example here, then I could say,
this might be at offset, I just made it up roughly, let's say 2500. So it's this byte position.
Therefore here I would have a header. Then I would write here, okay, my first tuple is at position
2500. And I must also know how large is the tuple. So if this here is for example 30 bytes,
then I write here 30.
So I store the offset in the page
and the length of the data item.
And this allows me to reference the data item itself.
Okay, so conceptually quite simple,
position and length.
Now I said conceptually quite simple
and reality can be slightly more complicated
than you might think
because there can be, in rare circumstances,
be cases where you want to store empty tuples.
You could say, why do you ever want to store empty tuples?
Trust me, there are cases where you want to do this.
Most obvious example, if you just store a single string, and the string cannot be null
and nothing else, so just a single string, then you might wish to just store the string
as it is in the tuple.
And then the length of the tuple is the length of the string.
And then because somebody can insert an empty string, of course, we can have empty tuples.
Now, if you say offset length, no problem, so I just put in the length zero.
Yeah, but now we have a problem that we must distinguish an empty tuple from a tuple that
was deleted, from a free slot basically.
And then if we do this like this, we say if my front slot is free, so there is no tuple
exists, then we drive right here zero zero, this means free slots, no space, so you can
just reuse it.
But if you want to store an empty tuple, so a tuple that does exist but just has the length
Then we store it with offset larger than zero, for example, one zero, and then we can distinguish
these two cases.
Okay.
So this one here exists as empty.
The other one does not exist and it's empty too, of course, but it doesn't exist.
So then we, otherwise this is our encoding, we just store offset in length in the, in
the slot.
Now so far everything looked great in the page where we say we just store the data and
if we don't fit, we put it on a different page.
a conceptually simple thing problem is there can be very ugly things happening
in combination with transactions so here's an example transaction load that
creates difficulties and also first assume that so i have a page this was my original page now
on this page i had a data item let's call this i1 and this was for example very large
Now transaction one comes and deletes this data item.
And of course I will have, I didn't draw this very nice.
Of course I also have a header in the slot.
So now transaction one comes and deletes this data item one.
And this is no problem.
Of course we can do this because now we have just free space.
Okay.
So this is easy.
We can just do this.
Okay.
Now transaction two is a new data item I2.
And after this, my page is full and really full.
I mean, here you see some free space because I didn't draw to the bitter end, but I assume
this is really, really full.
Now transaction one commits.
Okay.
Sorry, transaction two commits.
So at this point, this page is fixed, stored on the page and this is added as it is.
And now transaction one comes in the bolts.
Now we have a problem because we must put item 1 back.
So here we must put item 1, but I remember the page is full, I cannot put item 1.
Okay, now the theory says no problem, we just create an indirection, we put I1 on a different
page.
We have a new page and we just put I1 here.
And then I put a forward from this page to that page.
So this is the theory.
The problem is, the forward also costs space.
That's because if we think about this picture here, we saw this nice looking forward record
here, this takes up probably at least 8 bytes, perhaps more.
So this costs me space too.
And where do I put this?
Because if my page is full, then it's full.
So I cannot put.
So one option of course would be to move both i1 and i2.
So this would work.
Because then I just move I2 to another page too, then I have an interaction for I2.
But now I have space on the original page for both entries.
So this box is ugly to implement, very tricky to implement, because now suddenly we have
to look at three pages and so, yeah, so difficult to implement and we don't want to do this.
So we don't want the extra complexity.
Therefore, your life is much, much, much, much easier if you implement it differently.
implement if you store the tuple ID of a forwarded record
inside the slot.
Which means you take the slots that you have on the page
and inside this, you store the new tuple ID
if it was forwarded.
And if it was not forwarded,
of course then we point the original space.
And we can do this if we can borrow one bit
from the tuple ID, which we often can,
or we have some other way to detect some invalid tuple ID.
And for example, you could say my tablid is, let's say eight bytes in size.
And I promise my topmost byte of my eight bytes will never be all one, so will never
be hex ff.
And this will never be the case for tablid.
And therefore, if I see this and I know this is not a tablid, so I can distinguish my entry
between a valid table ID and an invalid one, and if such a mechanism, then I can store both
a regular slot and a table ID in the same space.
Now a disadvantage of course is this wastes a bit space, because now my slots must be
as large as my table IDs.
And my table IDs, remember here, when we said it's probably 8 bytes at least, 8 bytes,
That's why here we just need offset and length.
And if my page size is at most 16 kilobytes, so I could do this with two byte and two byte
to mean four byte would be enough if my space is 16 kilobytes, oh, sorry, not 64.
If my page is at most 64 kilobytes, then I could do this with two byte and two byte.
Okay.
It's larger than I need four byte anyway.
So that's not a problem.
If it's larger than 60 kilobytes, then we need larger entries anyway.
But if it's at most 60 kilobytes, I could use four byte slots, so two byte and two byte.
But trust me, you don't want to do this.
What you want to do, sorry, too fast.
What I want to do is, you want to use eight bytes for the slot and use this eight bytes
to encode both offset length encoding and the table ID.
is much, much easier if you do this, because this terrible problem here that we don't have
enough space for the undo never happens.
Because if we undo, we always have space in the slot itself.
And so we can always forward it, no problem, because the slot itself gives me space to
store the forward.
Now this is much easier to implement, and therefore I warmly recommend you to do this.
And I think in the exercises you will implement this, therefore this is not only a theoretical
argument, but you will probably become familiar with the implementation of a slotted page.
And therefore you want to do this, store the tuple ID of a forwarded tuple in the slot
itself, much easier.
Okay.
And so then, then this is one way we can be implemented.
So one possible slot implementation looks like this.
So in total here, we have eight bytes in my slot.
Yeah, so this is in total is each box is one byte.
So these are eight bytes.
So and then we say, we'd look at the first byte.
If the first byte is not or another etc.
Next in the beginning is not OXFF.
So it's not all bits set, then the whole eight bytes are tablid.
So then this here can be, this is a tuple ID if t is not equal to OXFF.
So then this is a tuple ID and then this slot points to another record.
So then point to the original record.
Okay, otherwise if t is not this, then we, sorry, if t is equal to OXFF, then it is a
regular slot.
Okay, then we look at the next byte and then we say, if this here is an indicator to tell
me was this record moved from somewhere else, yes or no.
So I want to move this, sorry, I want to know this if my record was moved from somewhere
So if this is a zero here, then it was not moved from somewhere else, so standard case.
So then O and L just point to offset and length.
So we use 8 bytes for offset and 8 bytes for length.
And then we can encode, we can handle megabyte pages with this.
So we just encode everything with offset and length.
If S is not equal to zero, then in principle it's the same.
So again, we have tuple at offset and length, but the first eight bytes of the tuple now
contains the original tuple idea.
Now why do we do this?
So this here is a trick to speed up scanning.
And so this we use this speed up scanning.
This is important to get good scan performance if you ever have to move tuples.
do we do this? Remember when we come and look at this page here, when we read, I mean, if you could
use an index, we follow the chain, that's it. But if you do a table scan, table scan means we look at
every tuple in my relation. So I look at everything. If we do a table scan and I come to this page here
and then counter this record where it was moved, we do nothing. So we just ignore it,
because we know that we will see the pointer at some later point in time. So we do nothing,
the chain. Usually you read this record because it's correct in place, but we ignore this record.
Okay. Then at some later point in time, we encounter the second page and now we see the
original record that we had seen before. So at this point now I do read this. Okay. Now we do
to read this, but what I have to do now is I have to record the original table idea. I mean,
most of the times the table ID is invisible to the user, even though some database systems
what is the tuple ID, but we need this tuple ID,
for example, to do updates or deletes or so.
And delete on update first runs a query
to figure out which tuples are affected
and then performs update.
And for this cases, we need the tuple ID internally
to perform the change.
Therefore we must produce a correct tuple ID.
So in the moment that we read this,
we report the tuple ID not as,
so what we could report is five, six, seven,
and then 0, 0, 0, 0, 5.
We don't do this.
So don't report this.
Instead, we report 1, 2, 3, dot 7.
So we report the original tuple ID
so that if somebody updates,
then all the correct things happen.
But of course, we must know that this is the case.
We must distinguish the tuple
that is correctly placed on this page
and the tuple that was moved from somewhere else.
And this is what we do here.
sorry, this s-byte to indicate that the tupper was moved
and it was moved, then we store the original tupper ID
in front of the tupper, so that we can report it.
Now, so then when we scan it,
we report the original tupper ID
instead of its current physical position.
Okay, and with this trick, scans are very fast.
Also moving tupper costs you nothing in scan performance,
just in .excess.
Okay, so much about the pages.
I learned at least the basic in an introduction to database class, probably not as detailed
as we do it here.
And you will also do an implementation yourself because then you understand much better how
everything works.
But now we assume we have a slotted page mechanism.
So we can store basically my slotted page, it looks like this.
So I can store.
So here we say I have a few slots, header, slot, slot, slot, and then I have here tuple.
Now the next question is, what is in this box?
So how do we materialize the table?
And of course what we could do is we could just take all the attributes in my relation
and just write them as they are in this right range.
So here for example if an integer field we just write the number, 4, 5, 6, then we have
a string, then we can say for example, string 3, then we have ABC, then we have another
integer 2, 2, 2, and then we have length 5, a, a, a, a, a, so that's it.
Our civilization works, but this is not a good idea.
I mean, civilization gives me some great content.
I can store everything, I can read everything, but query performance is bad.
Now let's give, give this field a name.
Then let's say somebody says, let's call this A, B, this here now is a field C, D and this
here is a field E.
So assume somebody says, select some D from R.
So how do we do this?
We find the tuple and then I want to find D.
Okay, how do I find the position of D?
I first read the length of C and then I add the length of C to this position basically.
So I take this position here and do a plus and then I find the position of D.
Okay, so it means I have to do arithmetic to read a field.
Now we say this D is perhaps not that bad, if assume we have even more, let's say we
have another field F, so if I don't say some D but I do some F, then it's even more complicated.
I read C, then I find the position of, let's clear this carefully.
So I read the length of C, with the length of C I find the position of E, then I read
length of E and with the length of E I find F.
So clearly the excess cost for an attribute is linear,
at least in worst case, is linear
at the number of attributes that I have.
Because I have many string columns
and string columns are variable lengths,
I have to read all of the string columns
in front of the columns that I'm interested in
until I can compute the position of the attributes
that I want to have.
This is bad.
I mean, in this case I have only five attributes.
there are people who have hundreds,
thousands of columns in a tuple.
Okay, if you ask me, this is a bit crazy,
but I happen to know people
who have database systems
with many hundreds of fields
in a single relation.
And then O of N excess cost
is highly unattractive.
It's super expensive to access
the attribute at the end.
So serialization is not a good idea.
Now, what should we do instead?
So what we do instead is
We first, we do two things.
We split my tuple into two parts,
namely the fixed part and the variable size part.
So this is a fixed part.
And then this year is a variable length part.
Okay.
And now the entries in the fixed part
I can access in constant time, obviously.
So these were my fields,
A, B, C, D, E.
Okay, so this is the field A, this is the field B,
this is the field D and this is the,
oh no, did I make it correct?
Yes.
So, and then this here is the string C
and this here is the string E.
Okay, so I have moved the strings to the end.
And what I also did is inside the fixers part,
length as I did previously.
So on the previous slide, I said,
I saw the length of the string.
I don't do this.
Instead, I store the end of the string.
So I remember here, you will see this pointer drawn.
We store the end of the string.
Now, why is the end and not the beginning?
I mean, because first the beginning of C would be pointless.
I can just compute this as a position of C.
And you can ask why not the length?
Because the length itself does not help me
to find an entry.
And also because if I have many string columns and just store the length, then the offset
of string i is then the size of the fixed part, fixed plus the sum of the length of s, j, where
j is between one and i minus one.
Yeah, so this is also don't want to do this.
So I don't want to update all the length,
so this is bad.
Don't do this, but just do instead,
instead of storing the length is,
you store the end,
and then the length can be computed easily.
Because the length of a string now,
so the length of a string i,
Okay, string i is the end of i minus the end of i minus 1.
Okay, except for the first string, of course.
Because for the first string, otherwise it's end i minus size of fixed, fixed if i equal
zero.
Of course, for the first string is different.
First string is the end of the first string minus the fixed part.
But for all other strings, it's my end minus the end of the previous string.
Okay.
And this means that I can access any attribute in constant time.
The fixed size attributes I can access in constant time anyway, because it means they
are in the fixed size parts, so they are always the same position.
And the variable length elements, I can use this simple computation here and then I can
get the position and the length of every string in constant time.
So this is a pretty useful way to store variable length records.
Now, so to get even better performance, we start to reorder the attributes.
Now, we don't, I mean, in this case, I said I store them ABC, even though I split them
and fixed them in variable length, I store them as they were declared.
So ABC in the same order as in the table.
In reality, you do not want to do this.
So what you do instead is you separate in fixed and variable part of course, and in
for the fixed size part, you treat a string basically as two elements.
So a string is a length field as a fixed size and the data, this is variable size of course.
This is fixed and this is variable size.
And we really treat them as is.
So for the length, we treat them as a separate attribute.
Now we take all attributes that we have and we sort them by decreasing alignment.
Okay.
Now what does alignment mean?
Now, I'm not sure how familiar you are with hardware.
In particular, if you're only used to Intel architectures, you probably are not used to
problems with alignment because the Intel processor is nice to you.
Basically alignment means, so if I have an aligned,
aligned, how do you call this?
Aligned variable, yeah.
How do you write this?
So aligned X means that if he takes the address of X,
we had to process here as a number.
This is a number, we take the address of x,
we interpret it as a number,
then we compute the reminder of dividing this here
by alignment of x.
And then this here must be equal to zero.
Now so basically the address of a variable
must be a multiple of the alignment of the variable.
Okay, this is then we consider this as aligned.
Now it didn't explain what aligned is.
In first approximation, this is not exactly true,
but in first approximation, this here is the size.
At least for basic types, size of x.
So which means an integer,
this is four bytes in size,
and therefore has an alignment of
Line, line, so much just to write here.
It says an alignment, let's just write a,
has an alignment of four.
Okay.
Long, eight bytes,
therefore alignment is eight.
Okay.
Size equals alignment, at least for base types.
Now, if you have compound types is no longer true,
because then if your compound type,
like you have a pair, for example,
you have a pair of integer, integer. So then this is 2 times 4 equals 8 bytes,
but alignment is only 4. But alignment is 4 because we only have to align each individual
entry. Each individual entry has 4 bytes, therefore we don't need an alignment higher than 4.
Okay, but this is just a, so a special case, so as long as we look only at individual fields,
then we don't have compounds, we just have single values, integers or whatever, time,
time for types, whatever.
And this, in all these cases for simple data types, alignment equals size.
Now, so we want that the address of a value is a multiple of the size of the value for
simple types.
And now why do you want to do this?
The answer is depends on your processor.
If you do a misaligned read,
so now first place like makes it a bit more clear.
Let's assume this here is my memory buffer.
This is my memory buffer.
This goes from zero to, I don't know, large number.
And then if I store an integer here,
let's say I have an int, let's call this A.
Then I have a byte, let's call this B.
Oops, sorry, B.
Then this is of course at position four, then at position five, we have another integer.
And let's call this C. Now, if you want to read the, this here is aligned, this here
is misaligned.
Okay.
Misaligned.
Because it's misaligned because its offset is not a multiple of four.
It offset is five, five is not a multiple of four, therefore it's misaligned.
Okay.
And now if you want to read A, no problem, you can do this.
You can see what happens depends on your processor.
If you do this on for example a spark processor, your program crashes.
Because the processor says you are not allowed to read a value that is misaligned.
If you do this on an Intel processor, Intel is nice to you, it can do the read.
Only thing is the read might be a bit slower.
The misaligned reads can be slower.
Although I should say in the past they used to be slower.
Nowadays or already since quite a few years, Intel processors have spent a lot of optimization
this. So on Intel processors, misaligned reads are just as fast as aligned reads, except for the
case that the read crosses the cache line boundary, which can happen. Now, of course,
it could be because you're misaligned, your value crosses to another cache line, then it can be
slower. So Intel is not that bad, but in other processors it's really bad. Either it's not
supported or it's really slow. Therefore, you want that all your values are aligned.
Okay, how can we make sure that everything aligned? We sort them by decreasing alignment.
So this works because alignment here, that my alignment is always the power of two.
Now so all my alignments are the power of two and therefore it's easy to see that if you take
powers of two and you sort them by decreasing a value and you sum them up, the current sum that
you have is always a multiple of the values that you have.
So for example, if you have some numbers, let's say my first attribute is 8 byte, 4
byte, let's call this a, b is 4, c is 8, d is 1, e is 4, for example like this.
Okay, then we sort them and then we get the numbers in sorted order, we get 8a, 8x, 8x,
C for B for E and then it lasts 1D.
So if you, and now if you compute offsets, this here would start offset 0, this here
would call it offset 8, this would call it offset 16, this would start offset 20, this
would start offset 24 and you see every offset that we get is a multiple offset alignment
by construction, because we made it like this,
by sorting them in decreasing alignments,
all my attributes will be properly laid out.
And we get on it, we get better performance
and other processes we prevent to crash.
So this is what we want to do.
We want to have some aligned
and the variable parts of the strings,
we consider them to have the alignment ones
that we just put them at the end.
And so at the end we would put the strings
because for strings alignment is not a problem.
strings, we read them character wise anyway.
Now strings you put at the end.
Okay, so this is what we do.
We rearrange them.
So then it no longer corresponds to the order
that it was declared in the table,
but this doesn't matter.
Well, because we, of course we remember the mapping.
We can still retrieve every attribute in constant time.
And by doing so you get better performance
without wasting any space on padding.
So because this is the alternative basically,
the alternative would be to use padding
and we do not want to do this.
So to illustrate what would happen here,
if you would mean there are basically two ways
to avoid misalignment.
One is reordering, this is what we do here.
Second one is padding, this we don't want to do.
Now, but I just want to show you how it would work.
Here we could lay out A, eight bytes,
and we would be at position eight.
Then we would lay out B,
and this is four bytes, afterwards we add 12.
Now I am not allowed to place C next, because if I would put C here, and so I would draw
this with a dotted box, we don't do this.
If I would put C here, then my C would be misaligned because alignment is 8, 12 is not
a multiple of 8.
So what we could do then is we waste space, so basically we have four bytes here padding,
wasting, wasted space that we don't use, up to 16.
And then we can of course put the C again.
Yeah, so up to, then up to 24.
We don't want to do this because it wastes space,
it's a bad idea.
But this is what, for example, a C compiler would do,
or a C++ compiler.
They would do this.
They would enter padding.
So they would add space until everything is aligned.
The compiler also cares about alignment for you,
but it does it by adding padding.
What we prefer instead is we reorder the attributes
such that no padding occurs.
This is much better.
In C, the programming specification doesn't allow this.
So the compiler is not allowed to reorder attributes.
Otherwise it would be a good idea to do this in C2.
But in databases we can do this
because nobody except us will look at the data.
So this is a basic layout for a tuple.
Now so far I just said we just store all the values as they are.
Now there is a certain very undesirable value that unfortunately occurs in the database
system.
This is null.
So you know that by default every column is nullable, so you can insert any value or null.
And null represents an unknown or unspecified value and this is a special value that is
other value yeah of course if you want to do your database system a favor you declare the column to
be as not null so if you do a create table create table then you say x integer
not null so then your system knows oh this can have you been i and it can store it much more
efficiently so declaring a table as not a column is not null is a good idea unless of course you
really need null.
I mean, sometimes you want to store null because you want to cope with the fact that some values
are missing and then by all means, please use null, don't implement it yourself with some crazy
special values.
Use nulls if you have to.
So nulls are okay if you need them, but if you do not need them, then please declare the column
was not null.
So if we do it like this here, it's integer, we declared x is nullable, sorry, x is not nullable,
so it cannot be null, but y is nullable.
Okay, now how do we do this?
So if you do a record layout like this,
which I have, we just store x and y,
for x is everything's fine, but for y,
so if you just use four bytes here,
four bytes, what do we do is null?
Null is separate from every other value.
So now there are different,
And basically two different schools to implement this.
One is to say, I just pick one value that is invalid and that we use to represent null.
But this is usually not possible.
I mean, in some special cases it is.
For example, if you look about the IEEE representation of doubles, you realize that some values are
impossible and therefore you can use one of these values to represent a null.
but this is a special case if you just think about integers mean every value can
in this four byte range can occur and can be stored in the database you know so therefore we
we cannot store this now um this doesn't stop people from trying even though it's impossible
it doesn't stop people from trying what they usually do is for integers they take int min
And say int min here is null.
So this is what some people do.
Now, int min is a very, very special value.
I'm not sure if you're aware of this.
Integers gives me so large numbers.
Let's look here at a special case
because it's easier to think about this.
Let's think about int 8.
It has an 8-bit integer.
So 8-bit integer.
I only use this because it gives me
slide and the same is true for larger integers, but I only use 8 bits here.
If you look about this, this is a range from, there is of course a zero involved, then the
largest possible 8-bit integer is 127 and the smallest possible integer is minus 128.
This here is int min.
And you see that the domain is asymmetric.
So there exists a value, namely this one here, let's call this int min for this domain.
In min, there exists a value for which no positive number exists.
So if you take this number, try to compute this as x and then we compute minus x, we
can't represent this.
What happens is if you take minus 128 and you do minus on this, you end up again with
minus 128, which is of course a bit odd.
But the reason is the integer cannot represent this number.
The positive number is unrepresentable because the negative number is smaller, but the absolute
value of the negative number is a little higher than the largest possible positive number.
So this one here is special and this by the way creates all kinds of problems.
For example, if you want to crush your program hard, so if you take a programming language
of your choice, I mean, no, not your choice, because there's a really high level one, they
check against this.
Take a nice, simple, low level language like C.
And then you take int min, now the real int min, of course, is 232, minus this one, yeah.
Oh, sorry, not two, one.
So this here is a, is a int min.
Yeah, and if you take this one here,
let's call this x.
And then if you compute x divided by minus one,
yeah, you do this in your code.
You say that equals x divided by minus one.
What do you think will happen?
I can tell you what will happen, your program will crash.
Your program will crash and you will get a signal and you will die.
So this is what happens and this is what most people don't expect.
I think most people are aware that this here is a bad idea.
So x divided by zero is clearly a bad idea, so this will also crash and people are aware
of this.
What people are not so aware of is that this here will crash too if x is equal to int
min and only in this case.
Here every other value is okay, but int min, if you divide int min by minus one, your program
will crash.
And so this means that int min is a very unpleasant value and some people say, hey, you know what,
this is an ugly value anyway, just remove int min from my domain and if therefore we
use int min to represent null.
Because I say this is a forbidden number, nobody is allowed to use this and then now
I have gained a number that nobody is allowed to use and therefore I can just use this.
This looks reasonable until you realize that the first programmation is okay, but then
you realize other bad things that can happen.
Like this one here for example, x is 2 to the power of 30, not 31, 30.
Okay, no problem.
then you say y is minus x no problem either and then you say z is equal to y
plus y and now we have a problem because this year this new z value that I just
got is equal to int min which means you performed a computation on non-null
values, meaning this is clearly not null, 2 above 30 is a regular number, minus 2 above
30 is also a regular number, and now you take two regular numbers, you do a plus and the
result is null.
And this is something that you don't want to do, because it is semantically wrong.
Now there are two things you can do, either you ignore the problem and if the user happens
to compute null, then okay, this is of course, don't do this, this is bad, because then you
suddenly your database outputs null, even though it is wrong, don't do this.
alternative is after every computation you must check if the result happens to be in min and if
yes you produce an error okay this is also possible but this costs you performance yeah so
you don't want to do this also it's ugly to implement and so now so therefore i would say
don't do this if you can avoid this now especially values from the domain is
difficult surprisingly difficult to implement i mean it looks attractive at first glance because
Because you can say I can still store this as regular integer, need nothing special.
But this is just misleading because you get a lot of complexity by treating this special
value special.
So therefore a nicer thing is to say I just use one separate bit, a null indicator that
says I have an x value x and I have a separate bit here that says x null.
Now a separate bit, and then I can store every possible value in x, no problem.
I just check is my null bit set.
If yes, I ignore the x value because it's null, otherwise I use the value.
So using a null bit allows me to omit the value from storing.
This means when I store the value, I mean the disadvantage of course is it must store
the null bit.
Clearly, I must store one bit more.
On the plus side, if I have a null value, I can at least sometimes choose a representation
that just stores the null bit and then treats this x as variable size and kicks out the
x.
So we don't store the x.
So now this of course is a trade-off.
If I do this, access to my values become more complicated because of variable size things
and so on the plus side, I save space because I use only one bit.
So this is also called null compression and this is useful if you have a lot of null values.
And so if many of your values are null, then this is a good technique.
Downside of course is complexity and excess cost.
Okay, but this already brings me to the next part of how do we store tuples, namely,
what about compression?
Now, so some database systems want to store the database in a compressed form.
And yes, there are actually good reasons to do this.
But first you should realize most of the time we do not compress data to save space.
I mean, it's not always true.
Some people really care about space, but most people do not care about space so much.
What we usually care about is performance.
So we compress data to get better performance.
Now why is this so?
So let's do the math.
So assume hypothetically I have my data here is 200 megabytes of data and if I query this
then I need, I have to read this from, for example, from a disk that can read 200 megabytes
per second, then I need for this one second.
Then after, so this here is IO, input outputs from disk, one second.
Now, if instead of having 200 megabyte, I can compress this to, if I instead compress
this to 100 megabyte, then I only need half a second of IO.
So I gained a factor two in performance because my data size was reduced by factor two.
And this is what I'm interested in.
And also we reduce the space to reduce bandwidth consumption.
Bandwidth is limited, often not always, but often is limited.
And therefore I compress my data to use less bandwidth and therefore improve performance.
So this is the main idea behind compression, because the argument here is disk is cheap.
I can buy a very large disk for a little money.
So who cares about space?
But I mean, just to be totally honest with you, I learned this is not always the case.
I know at least one company that cares about space because of customer experience.
So you could say, who cares about it?
You just buy a larger disk and this is absolutely true.
Disks are cheap and so who cares about this?
But if you ship your product to a customer and the customer experiences a full disk,
Therefore, you try to avoid this.
You try to compress the data, even though it might have been a visor choice to just
buy a larger disk.
But nevertheless, some people care about disk.
But this is the exception.
Most people primarily care about performance.
And therefore we compress data to improve performance.
So this is also here on the bottom of the slide, you see written here, some people do
care about space, mostly embedded database systems where really space is limited.
server database systems compression is, space consumption is not that critical usually.
Of course you don't want to waste space, but it's not as urgent. But for performance reasons,
you always want to, are interested in compression. Okay, now how to compress?
So if you look at general purpose compression schemes, I hope you are familiar with at least
some of these. If you look at general purpose compression schemes, you see the larger the
works now for example if you think about the classical compression at lz77 now this is uh
one of the most mainstream compression schemes you take a large buffer and then you write in here
some for example abcd and so on then you say oh you know what take this sequence again and repeat
it five times as was the back pointer followed by frequency you see takes this five times and then
Then perhaps just take the g and then put it 10 times and so on.
This is how a classical asset 77 works.
We reference the data that we have outputted before.
We do a back pointer and a repeat count and then we reference this.
And this works the better, the larger the buffer is.
Clearly if you have a tiny buffer, so if my buffer contains just three values, I have
I have no redundancy at all,
so I cannot compress anything.
And so if my data is very small, I cannot compress it.
It has to be large enough
so that I see enough repetitions to compress my data.
So this is classical runoff simulation schemes,
and they want to have large compressed chunks
to improve performance.
But the problem is to improve compression.
Problem is we don't want to have large compressed chunks
because otherwise you cannot update very well.
I have compressed a five megabytes of data
and I want to update something in the middle.
Now, how should I do this?
I mean, I could decompress everything,
do the update and recompress everything,
but this is not so super attractive.
Yeah, so it's quite expensive.
Also other problems are,
what about page size, for example?
So it could be that somebody performs an update
and after this update, compression rate is much worse.
I mean, not super likely, but can happen.
And then suddenly it no longer fits on the page where it was before and everything is
ugly.
So compressing large chunks is good for compression, but bad for the database system.
What would work much better would be to say, okay, I compress each individual tuple.
So I compress one tuple and I compress the next tuple.
Compress the tuple by tuple.
This is both good for updates because I can then update a single tuple as I want and also
for handling.
Because in the lower layers, so the slotted page,
if you think about this layer here,
the slotted page only knows it has a byte range.
So my record here has a sequence of bytes.
I don't care what the content is.
It's this here, compressed, uncompressed, doesn't matter.
Now, so for the slotted page,
slotted page only has to know how large is the record.
So we have a range of bytes, and this is what we store.
Compression or not, totally unimportant for the slotted page.
So therefore, it's from the layering perspective, it is attractive if the compression is implemented
on top of the slotted page layer.
So the slotted page layer doesn't care, it just says, okay, I store a tuple.
And then I compress each tuple.
But still doesn't tell me how should I compress it.
Using a general purpose scheme like LZ77 is too expensive.
We don't want to do this.
significant cost for compression and also for decompression and second if you just compress a single tupper then
It doesn't compress very well because probably we don't have a lot of redundancy in there
Now so this is too expensive or if you look I mean in reality if you look at something like zip
It's just even worse. It's not only as a 77, but for example, you also add another Huffman encoding or or
Arithmetic encoding or something. Yeah, so we have to type some bit bit encoding on top of the SS 77
And this is all super expensive and we don't want to do this
because otherwise all your performance
will be burned in decompression.
And after all, we compress for performance reasons.
You have to be compressed to improve performance.
Therefore, if my compression is expensive, we lose.
And my data gets smaller, but I get slower
because all my time is burned in decompression.
And therefore we don't want to do this.
By the way, this brings me to a sad tale of my younger days.
So when I was a, I think I might even have been a real student like you or a PhD student,
but at least I was still, perhaps I was a PhD student.
But shortly after my studies, I encountered a very beautiful compression scheme that I
thought would be very nice to implement in a database system.
And you know, on paper it looks very well and reality is not that super great.
This is something that's called adaptive Huffman.
Now you are probably familiar with Huffman encoding.
You know, so Huffman encoding
does basically does the following.
You take your symbols and in your dictionary
and then assign them weights
and from the weights compute decision trees.
For example, you say, if I say a zero,
then I get a symbol A.
If I say a one, then I have another decision point here.
then I get this, if I get a 1 and a 0, then I get the symbol B.
And otherwise, if I get another 1, then I say, okay, if I get a 0,
then I have another decision point, 0, 1, 1, 0, oh, sorry, 0, 1.
So then we get here A, B, C, D, E, and F.
So this is for an example for a Huffman tree.
Now if he encodes the data that contains a lot of As and also a lot of Bs, then I get
very small encoding.
For example, because if my input here is AABDA, then this here is encoded as 00, oh this is
supposed to be a B, sorry.
Sorry, B. My B is encoded as one zero, my D is encoded as one one zero one and my A
again is encoded as zero.
So then to encode this here, we have five bytes of input but as output we just need
nine bits as output.
And so we compressed eight bytes into nine bits.
And so this of course is great, much smaller.
And so this works beautifully, except,
so this is a compression scheme here,
except for the unpleasant problem.
How do I know that my tree is like this?
Because I mean to decompress the data,
I must know this tree.
I must know this Huffman tree.
So if I would of course I could see rise this tree as a good source a tree
But this would also cost me quite a bit of space as if I if I write the tree out first
Then I my encoded schemes larger than input
Yeah, so this only makes sense if I compress a reasonably large input because otherwise my serialized
Huffman tree is larger data
So what's the point as a half an encoding does not work if you have to ship the tree
Meaning if the tree is known if you can always use the same trees, that's okay
trips the tree, then half-minute coding doesn't work because the tree itself is too large.
Now comes adaptive half-minute coding.
This is a really brilliant idea.
Again, choose my input A, what was the input?
A, A, B, D, A I think was my input.
So and how does adaptive half-minute coding work?
It says in the beginning if I know nothing, I assume everything has the same probability,
The original tree, for example, looks like this.
0, 1, 0, sorry, I should have drawn it.
There is a longer, more gap between this.
So let's say, this is my root.
If I get a 0, I go here to the left.
If I get a 1, I go here.
1, 0.
If I get a 0, I go here.
one I go here,
and sorry, and if I forget another zero I go here,
I should have drawn one more to the right.
One, and then zero, one, zero, one,
and then of course I label this here with,
Then A, B, and C, D, and so on.
Then of course some more.
Now as the first symbol comes, I just encoded it as it is.
In this case I say for example three As.
Then I realize, oh you know what, the A is more frequent than other symbols, so let's
change the encoding.
Now, then I didn't draw an ideal scheme for this, but just for example, pretend that I
do the following, you know, to be honest, this is not what the real adapter does, but
I cannot dynamically reorder my tree so easily.
I can, for example, say this, I make the A, give A a shorter code and to B, which has
not occurred yet, I give, for example, this code here.
So then comes another A and just give it a 0, 0.
And then again I update this.
And then I move this tree somewhere else.
So I give the 0, 0 to an A. And then the CD I put for example here.
Of course, as I said, the real reordering is different, but I cannot dynamically build
a real adaptable half a tree here.
But I give it different weights.
So I update my tree, and then comes my B, B gets the number that it has here, in this
case 111, and then if we update the B2, then we make B cheaper.
Then comes my D, and my D now gets 101, 101, and then of course I also update the D, and
a is in this case, I just get a zero.
And this means that of course, in the beginning, the a was more expensive because I didn't
know that a was frequent.
But so this was the first a, this was the second a, and this is the last a.
We see so the frequent numbers get shorter codes over time.
And the infrequent number gets longer, of course.
So this is what happens.
And the good thing is, in this scheme, we do not have to transfer the tree because the
weights.
So when both during compression and decompression, we update the tree all the time.
And so the trees is passed implicitly.
And this allows us to run Huffman coding even for short inputs.
Absolutely great idea.
Yeah.
So only problem is it works terribly.
Because this does not have reasonable performance.
Adaptive Huffman looks great.
So if you just see it on a paper, it says, hey, this is really a nice idea.
So much better encoding, really good,
until you start to implement this.
First, it's not so easy to implement.
You saw already that I could not easily update the tree.
I, in fact, I cheated.
So my tree was no longer an adaptive huffin tree
because it was too complicated to change this.
So updating the tree is not that easy.
There's a lot of code.
And second, it's quite expensive.
Yeah, therefore, I mean,
I have indeed implemented this at some point
and ran it in a database system.
which was okay, then you run a query,
so you want to decompress it,
and performance was terrible, really terrible.
Why?
Because all the time was spent on decompression.
And this means that compression was a bad idea.
After all, we want to compress to become faster.
And therefore we must choose encoding schemes
that are cheap.
And for this reason, in fact,
usually we will not use a Huffman encoding,
because Huffman encoding is a bit level encoding.
So we use a variable number of bits per level.
This is quite expensive.
We prefer, not always, but we will prefer to use byte-wise encoding,
which means we give a data element 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, as many as it needs bytes,
but not individual bits.
Why? Because we can manipulate bytes much more cheaply than bits.
Therefore we prefer byte-level encoding over bit-level encoding.
Even though of course, bit-level encoding compresses better, no question about this.
bit level encoding gives me smaller data,
but it costs me more CPU instructions to decompress.
And therefore we usually prefer byte level encoding.
Okay, so now this is one way to how we can implement this.
For example, we can represent an integer like this.
Of course, because I just said,
we want to do everything byte level
and relatively this will be stored in different bytes,
problem for now.
So we just say each integer can be represented like this.
We have a two-bit header.
So we have a two-bit header field.
And then we have zero to four bytes of data.
And these two bits here, we can store four different values.
And according to environment A, for example, is this one here.
So we say if my header field is all zeros, then I use one byte of data.
Now, if most of my integers are short, I just store two zeros and then one byte.
smaller than 4 bytes that I would need for the full integer.
If my data is too large, so it's a number that's above 256 or if it's side above 127,
then I store there a 0,1.
So say I need 2 byte values and I can store 2 bytes.
If it's even larger than this, I store 1,0, I can store 3 byte values and then in the
maximum case I write 1,1 and I can store 4 byte values.
And if most of the integers are short or shorter at least than the full 4 bytes, then you save
quite a bit of space.
This is an encoding scheme that is easy to implement, cheap, because I just need to read
two bits and then do everything byte wise afterwards.
So this can be done quite cheaply.
And you can also use this to handle null values if you want.
And because instead of having this extra null bit, you can use this encoding scheme to represent
nulls.
You say if my header field is all zeros, then I said, oh, I have a null value and this here
therefore null bytes in size, I have no entry.
If I get to 0, 1, then I have one byte,
if we get to 1, 0, I have two bytes,
and if we get to 1, 1, I have four bytes.
Of course, I lose, I cannot represent this case here anymore,
but on the plus side, I can represent null values.
And probably it's not that common that I need three,
but not four bytes.
So I can do this.
And I can use this to compress integer values quite well.
And this is cheaply,
it can be done for each individual attribute.
Now, downside of course is if you do this, if you do integer encoding like this, my originally
fixed size entries, my integers become a variable size because I have different lengths.
Yeah.
So this is a bit problematic.
So locating a compressed attribute becomes more expensive because now it means I have
to look at the previous entries that are compressed.
Yeah.
But in reality it's not that bad.
It costs something, but we can implement it.
So what we do is we start as usually,
we start the fixed part in the beginning,
the real fixed part of course.
Then we look at the length, just at the length bit.
Remember I said we want to store everything byte wise.
Therefore what we will do is we will take four
of these two bit length indicators
and store them in one byte.
So this is one byte here.
We store this in one byte.
And now to access, for example, this attribute or any of them would require us to look at
the previous lengths in theory, but then in principle we would have to do this.
But because we know that one byte can have only 256 possible values, we can pre-compute
this.
So we know if you see this byte in my length indicator, then my fields will be at this
position and will have that length.
lookup table that for every possible length byte gives me the positions of
length of each field and then decompress is again pretty cheap. I mean it costs a
few instructions but it's pretty cheap, much cheaper than if you would really
individually decompress each individual byte. So now with the lookup table we can
make it much more handleable. Another popular technique that we can use to
compress data is we can use dictionary encoding and this is primarily relevant
I mean, people are very fond of strings.
People tend to have a lot of data in their database
that is stored as strings.
And this data tends to be redundant.
For example, if you store address information
of customers, of users,
then you might have, for example,
a few people who live in the same city.
Like your city of Berlin might occur a few times
or city of Munich might occur a few times.
Instead of storing this string each and every time, you can store it only once in a dictionary.
And then for example, say my string Berlin has a number one, my string Munich has a number
two, and my string Passauerstrasse for example has a number three.
And in fact, it happens to be that this Passauerstrasse exists in both cities.
So that therefore if you have a tuppel, you have a tuppel that says I live in city one
in street three.
Another one says I live in city two, street three.
Passauer Straße in different cities, but you store the string only once.
And in the table itself, you store only nice integer IDs.
We just store an integer.
Integers are smaller than the strings and also much more efficient to handle.
So by doing this, you save a lot of redundancy.
In fact, I jokingly heard from a database vendor who said, it would be a good idea to
to ship the database with the name of all US states,
because the state names occur very, very frequently
in datasets.
And probably if you store country names,
US cities, sorry, US state names and so on,
and you have them preloaded somewhere,
instead of storing it in the database,
you can compress quite a few data by datasets
by using this.
Of course, this is domain specific
if you have a lot of customer from the US.
If you have customers from Germany,
be better to store German city names.
Of course you cannot know this beforehand, therefore we of course do not store them in
the database binary, but we just recognize them in the dataset.
So we can pull out common strings and store them only once.
And really, strings are extremely frequent, much more frequent than you might think.
I mean, we in the introduction to databases teach everybody, ah, you should store data
nicely in a normalized form and then factor out common entries and then you have fields as they
make sense and of course you should do this everything is right problem is people don't do
this yeah so people very very frequently store data redundantly yes you have this here you have
records that yes you have safe here abc uh sorry then abc again then abc again and i mean abc is
still short yeah could be this can be long strings stored over and over again all the same string i
if you look at this you could say hey please store the string in a separate table and just
reference with the four key but people don't do this yeah in fact then there are uh
products like sap said at least historically stored everything as a string really everything
even numbers yes everything was stored as a string and um mean uh you mean you could say
why do this yeah it has historic reasons because when this was first developed database systems
data types and the only data type was really robust across database systems
every database system treated is more or less the same was a string and therefore
they said okay we just store everything as a string and then we can control
everything and then we have no problems of course they don't do this very bad
idea to do this at least nowadays performance will be terrible you will do
everything in your application don't do this but nevertheless if you look at
datasets people have a lot of strings and making your string smaller is a good
Dictionary compression is one technique.
As you are to other techniques,
like you can try to compress within the string
because here we in a particular compression,
you only store the string, the same string once,
but if the strings differ, you store them multiple times.
You can try to be even more aggressive.
For example, if you realize that you have a lot of strings
that look like this,
http.or slash less than
Google or something,
or you have http
http
dot dot slash
dot dot dot dot
tom
and so on and you can realize
of course these individual strings will be
stored only once but we can also
realize that oh this prefix here
occurs quite frequently
let's pull it out
so we can use
prefix compression in my dictionary so that
stored only once then reuse
and neighboring entries, or you can be even more aggressive,
but I don't want to spend a lot of time on compression.
I'm just saying, try to compress your data is a good idea.
Only balance you have to find here is,
don't waste too much CPU time on compression,
because otherwise your decompression is too expensive.
And so there's a certain balance here
that we have to choose between how aggressive you compress.
But in general, compression is good for performance reasons.
Okay, so I think if I look at the time,
the end, let me briefly look.
Yeah, so I'm at about at the end of what I want to talk
about today.
One problem is that we did not cover yet is what to do
if my record is too large, because if you think about
the started pages, you always said, okay,
am I record here?
I have a fixed size page, for example, 16 kilobytes,
or could be large of course, but it will be fixed size.
and then my tuple is stored here.
What I do if a user inserts a database with a string
that is larger than 16 kilobytes.
And now what happens differs between the database systems.
If you do this in Oracle,
you just simply get an error message.
Oracle says, no, you're not allowed to do this.
Tuple must fit on a page.
If a tuple is larger than a page, then I don't accept it.
But this makes unhappy users
because users want to store long strings.
And so we need a mechanism for this.
And second, even in systems who do not support us
for arbitrary records, nearly everybody has a,
you can declare a field to be large.
There you can say I have a blob.
The blob means binary large object,
which means this is now large and I want to store this.
Please store a large binary data for me.
Or if you want to have a large string,
you can call this clop, character large object.
You tell the database system this is long,
please store this for me.
And therefore we need a mechanism to handle this,
And this is what we will do, look at next.
Okay, thank you.